okay so here you can down get pushing
giving some linear version of a salt
right it's final displacement in social
violence range and penetration so I am
mu kid in other words we don't do that
do you see that there's no there's no
energy here there's no attacked as note
there's no conflict as long as I go I
don't mind you holding my hand do you
see that so we always use the wrist
strap as an abstraction for this final
displacement you guys understand okay we
tend not to do pulling exercises either
not at the beginning only because
they're just so easy to deal with
he pulls I'm a black belt he's pulling
you you enter so if we go to tighten
emedco and we reverse-engineer it he's
turning so you know by default even if I
didn't know all that other information
that who gives what
pushing okay you guys okay here's the
problem though is your mind is seeing
this point at the wrist grab as what is
most important and so it starts to set
up the dichotomy we meet here in the
middle the middle requires two ends he's
on one end I'm on the other and you
start functioning around here okay what
I'm advocating for you to do is yes he
comes in and but the techniques are
actually going to start
so even if I am doing Jo dog you see the
technique I'm not actually pivoting
around this point you see that own
technique is going over here over here
okay so watch pay attention to my Center
how I'm making that happen
what you see wait there's a weight shift
and then in relation to what yes it's
pushed and there's a media there's no
conflict errors immediately
boom and you bring them in and you
change where it wanted to manifest you
could actually make that your goal if I
leave it there in my mind and I act like
it's there then I am participating in
the conflict but if I immediately take
it over here then I have done of the
first conflict resolution you guys see
that well then the question is how do
you do it so even when I'm doing
title I know it's not here
there's the first clue is a tiny shift
you see that it's a tiny shift tiny mole
in turn turn and just like everything
can be better it could be internal
it could be internal this year relax
it just can't be this can't be there
okay in here no
and so my wristwatch how I'm going to
create space for his grip so if I hold
it it's in space here the conflict
starts but I'm going to give him more
range by adding the spiral do you see
that so in other words take your hand
there when I go like this his hand has
all that distance to reconcile the
conflict and not push on me so if I just
go straight across this part is as long
but not the part that coiled under
that's a good extra two to three inches
and that also gives you your angle
cancellation on the elbow add to that my
weight shifting room and I have quite a
lot of space to absorb in energy
oh man the conflicts over here so what's
the conflict passes meeting up oh my
in turn file home insert turn injury adv
is always in the free space so if I keep
this year that's not free space even if
I torque his thumb it's not free space
so when I go over here look when I enter
I'm past the point of conflicts when you
can't push on the whole then you can't
stop this for nothing because I'm
nowhere okay so boom this step change
the idea of everything same things
okay so here I'm gonna stop the
technique and go ahead and push it's not
mushy okay push hard I start to turn
push hard it's not pushy I still have
the same projection capacity okay so
it's the same form but I'm taking all of
this energetic
and not using it to push back on them
here's why you're not stepping here is
important
you guys need all my fish go back to
reasons you're doing it depend you still
have the total estates antagonism like
we can still push on me even though I
I'm grounded that's how what we're
trying to do inside momento okay so as
we're here like this if I don't step he
can still there's still a lot of energy
there but the second I move this there
there's no more energy coming towards
because it's going forward and I move
into this right here there's a lot of
energy right there step and then turn
and now it's off it's going that way
okay then because this risk rubbing
energy is it just an abstraction for
spinal displacement it's not a risk crab
attack right so you have to watch the
ways in which you're making it or this
crab attack one of the things if you're
training properly it should be able to
be a ballistic attack - it could be a
tackle it could be anything can be a
knife so I don't want to risk rap and
see how I stopped him that's the
dichotomy he's set up that's the
reification of the wrist brown why
should not the young reconciliation
happen already here so I'm pulling his
intention in not going like this and his
job is to follow me wherever I go you
can about an inch or two of his mind
that's about it
it's the same thing if we're in tight
and he throws a strike right oh that
would be wrong this is wrong but little
that's right he's going to go right for
that strike do you see that do you guys
what I'm trying to say what am I trying
to say someone say
be able to not let them read you to let
them to be able to to go through with
this motion without okay and what lesson
what allows this motion what level of my
actually fighting at my the mind level
okay so you just already hit me I'm
using it against them you can about an
inch or two do you understand not not
this that that's too far you get about
into just like we technique I show you
okay so there is this is wrong but then
this is equally wrong both that time it
then therefore I'm not pulling it I
don't stop them set up the conflict and
then I hold him I'm not doing that I
agree to it and we'll just watch
slow-motion again so here's the issue
you just get that little lean and I'll
try and stop it in there right there
okay now I'm going to take his weight
like that so he's just perpetually
falling you see that there's a timing to
it it's not external stop hold and then
I move into this space it's dynamic
leave balance goes that way his initial
attention makes you go where I need to
go where might even go how far you go
okay try me so now that I don't have the
conflict and you can see that he's
rotating around me then I'm in harmony
with his intention which was assigned to
go forward okay I'm gonna take the tape
off and just put myself in this
the empty space that's right here since
tennis stepping back I just stand in the
middle of this axis of rotation and I
start to first shrink the circle whoa
then I step into the empty space
underneath so absorb go back absorb
start the rotation
[Music]
okay that last rep is the one that it's
more obvious but it was obvious in all
the other ones you get is TARDIS
constrained in nerve center okay
to me it looks like Groucho
get over here sometimes it's you can't
but most of the time not yet so see how
it's just normal walk so I can make that
weird you see their cigarettes you know
okay so just a normal tie yourself if
you immediately going to keep her free I
need that Tara she's just free
[Music]
Hey
now we need even watch nothing changes
how can it go like this come lick lick
your conflict on the thumb you see that
here conflict conflict conflict stupid
there's your inch but watch my arm my
arm is going to do this same rotation
that's going to help condition you
[Music]
so either way you're going to see that
this energy is what's taking my hormone
not me you could do some craziness
here's the thing if he just script
follows the rules he's armed
don't do it yeah you see what happens so
sorry but what does ever you kid do they
just start to turn on themself like what
why maybe I want know do you see maybe I
walked out here you should be able to do
it look at this difference did you keep
your grip you don't have to do anything
see this is that you stay on this look
see it down boy it's good to turn that
was not gonna turn so let's do this two
differences here and you can keep Sigrid
here we're gonna be here
[Music]
yes
okay so even on the dude that's just
gonna grab my hand with no penetration
okay even on that too
you get your DC you get your 1/2 inches
you get them every time
not if you do it like this though he
just wants a little old your hand and
stop so you have to stay in harmony with
that here he comes
well that was it he came in and you pass
through get done chewed on his energy
that came forward will push it up to Joe
dog be mindful that you're not making
this technique to overhear them you see
it all happens much smaller
[Music]
then not just like each joke just like
hope you whole you've made the top young
the bottom is been entered through
connect to Center integer
[Music]
different technique okay
so work either the to be mechanics and
then you have the single big mechanics
okay it's not that my arm is making a
circle and twinning
you see that differently it's gonna be
your house Delta and you're not getting
the conditionings of the inward and
outward spirals okay so this is just
dumbness then you go to this that's not
what we're doing that's also why you
can't do the 1b time if you have a to
beat movie line to this movement is in
here I'm gonna go really slow in here
whoa get down spiral chewed on spiral
energy pushes it up
I'll do the wrong version you're drawing
a big outer circle with your wrists the
correct version look at the yield won't
you see the typing of the body wall whoa
wrong merging out of the deltoid spiral
just this actually circle other one
watch my elbows body hole
this version I don't even feel it just
do the technique
you